c'est l'heure de notre second débat il
est vous le savez c'est notre choix
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour il va nous plonger dans l'univers
du metaler ce monde parallèle dans
lequel on peut se créer un avatar
acheter des vêtements ou des œuvres
d'art numérique par exemple c'est ludix
ça fait rêver mais ça pollue on va donc
se demander avec nos experts si l'on en
a vraiment besoin mais d'abord Marion
Vigreux pédagogie toujours dans cette
émission elle nous initie au lieu de
travers
le métaverse est un monde virtuel
parallèle où chaque utilisateur peut
mener une vie numérique via un avatar un
personnage qui le représente dans cet
univers trois ou quatre dés le degré
d'immersion est renforcé grâce à
l'utilisation d'un casque de réalité
virtuelle comme dans la vie réelle les
utilisateurs peuvent se rencontrer et
interagir entre eux
ce n'est pas mieux que de rencontrer
quelqu'un dans la vie réelle mais je
n'aurais jamais l'occasion de rencontrer
mon ami japonais Finland argentin et
irlandais dans la vraie vie en même
temps ça n'arrivera jamais
autre possibilité dans le métaver
assister à des conserves visitez des
sites touristiques faire du shopping ou
même encore travailler cette année lors
du Salon de la tech à Las Vegas
plusieurs plateformes étaient présentées
dans cette ville vous pouvez faire tout
ce qu'il est possible de faire dans une
vraie ville imaginez un vrai magasin un
cours un entretien d'embauche une
réunion de direction l'allocution d'un
patron tout cela peut désormais avoir
lieu dans une structure géniale que vous
construisez dans notre ville
depuis le mois d'août le géant Facebook
qui est devenu meta à lancer en France
et en Espagne son état vert horizon
World déjà accessible depuis l'année
dernière aux États-Unis il compte près
de 300 000 utilisateurs et 10000 mondes
créés mais déjà des questions de
modération se posent ces univers ne
répondent à aucune législation et déjà
des cas de harcèlement ou d'agression
ont été signalées tout comme le risque
accru de collecte de données
personnelles
on va évidemment revenir sur cette idée
de protection des utilisateurs mais
d'abord demander tout simplement à quoi
ça sert avec mes invités à ce moment-là
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes maître de
conférence à Sciences Po Paris
spécialiste des enjeux politiques du
numérique Hélène Sanders bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste scientifique
réalisatrice de documentaire et vous
avez publié ce roman replay ou replay
chez Albin Michel qui nous embarque dans
l'univers et les dérives de la réalité
virtuelle j'accue également Maxime et
Free s bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
référent technologies numériques au
shift project et Mathieu croissanto est
resté à mes côtés évidemment alors ça
sert à quoi je commence avec vous à ce
moment
alors à quoi ça sert c'est une très
bonne question pour y répondre je vais
pas y répondre directement je vais déjà
essayer de décrire ce que c'est donc
c'est ça va être une réalité immersive
qui va être un espèce de mix entre
réalité virtuelle pardon en réalité
augmentée et il faut absolument Serrier
pour comprendre le métaphore les trois
grandes familles d'usage si vous voulez
donc vous avez la première grande
famille d'usage celle dont on parle
beaucoup sur laquelle il y a énormément
de communication et de lobbying c'est le
shopping donc c'est tout toute la partie
un peu commerciale marketing etc vous
avez une deuxième partie on achète pour
son avatar on est bien d'accord non vous
achetez pour vous même via votre avatar
on va dire mais bon on achète un objet
virtuel pas forcément toujours
et se faire livrer en passant par le
métal
vous allez l'essayer en réalité
augmentée etc vous êtes super content
vous l'achetez là vous allez en boutique
peu importe
et puis après vous avez aussi le web 3
les NFC etc qui est un peu
deuxième grande famille d'usage je
termine quand même rapidement c'est
les réseaux sociaux ou en tout cas la
nouvelle génération de réseaux sociaux
ou d'interactions sociales celle-ci pose
énormément de problèmes politiques
géopolitiques on y reviendra et puis la
troisième famille d'usage c'est les
simulations pédagogiques d'apprentissage
médical militaire etc et qui peut être
pour le coup celle-ci assez intéressante
si elle est bordée d'un point de vue
juridique en tout cas on va venir à
l'aspect juridique on devrait dire et
Nacer les Métavers c'est ça plutôt que
le metaves on a plusieurs c'est qui se
sont déjà concurrence comment ça marche
alors là non mais est-ce que non alors
là je sais pas
peut-être la question je dis le métal
verse ou méta vert mais ta vert parce
que univers en français d'accord on fait
comme ça
mais je dis on devrait dire les metaves
parce que en fait expliquez-nous c'est
une très bonne question
c'est une excellente question parce que
en réalité
votre titre des missions est très bon
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est et
potentiellement on ne sait pas encore
définir ce que c'est que ce truc quel
méta vert donc chacun va avoir ses
définitions va avoir ses usages va avoir
ses acteurs ses écosystèmes et
typiquement quand Thierry bouton parle
du métaver européen en fait on s'est
toujours pas ce qu'il met lui derrière
ça donc je pourrais être tenté de dire
oui les metaves en fonction de ce dont
on parle allez on continue de parler un
peu de de business de ce Maxime et fouet
ce qui investissent le plus aujourd'hui
sont les les gens américains très
clairement je parlais de de Mark
Zuckerberg car rebaptisé Facebook en
méta c'est pas un hasard
alors j'ai pas les chiffres du coup je
sais pas qui investit le plus qui est
sur c'est que ça s'inscrit un peu dans
la dynamique actuelle du numérique où on
a des mots clés comme ça il y a alors
metaves c'est le c'est le dernier qui
est sorti on a ioti pour internet of
things
exactement il y a l'intelligence
artificielle blockchain crypto-monnaie
tout un tas de mots clés comme ça qu'on
lance qui permet de débloquer des
financements parce que c'est
l'engouement et mais on sait pas
toujours exactement ce qu'il y a
derrière et du coup je prends de la
casquette shift on sait pas toujours ce
qu'il y a derrière comme infrastructure
et c'est ça le problème du coup avec
notre vision shift c'est on veut
déployer des choses mais on est dans un
monde là où on se rend compte que le gaz
par exemple c'est une ressource
contrainte les métaux c'est des
ressources contraintes et donc à la
question de on veut déployer des
services et on dit que typiquement il y
a cette phrase qui revient souvent sur
le métaver ça n'aura de limite que notre
imagination c'est pas
ça aura de limite avant tout la taille
des infrastructures est-ce qu'on va être
capable de produire et du coup bon donc
il y a des investissements qui partent
qui sont les plus gros je sais pas se
poser et se poser la question du du
est-ce qu'on en a vraiment besoin de ce
que ça va coûter notamment en termes de
pollution numérique etc on va y venir en
détail
qu'est-ce qui comment vous le juger ce
développement du métaverse et nacender
alors c'est une idée déjà qui a 30 ans
puisque le premier métat univers faisait
l'objet d'un polar de enfin un livre de
science-fiction de 1992 donc c'est en
fait une vieille idée qui a été remise
au goût du jour par Zuckerberg mais je
dirais que le metaves à la sauce
Zuckerberg c'est l'avenir du Web
c'est-à-dire qu'on va arrêter de de
d'aller sur internet avec le clavier on
ira avec un casque de réalité virtuelle
et ça il faut imaginer un méta vert a
forcément
recours à des à de nouveaux outils donc
le casque ou les lunettes voir des gants
aptiques pour sentir les choses des
gants à petit pour le toucher
et donc de rentrer dans l'écran et via
notre avatar d'être en interaction avec
les autres alors je je vous rejoins ça
peut avoir vraiment des des
ça peut ouvrir des opportunités
incroyables notamment en santé moi je
suis très sensible au sujet de la santé
et alors pour tout ce qui est soin
antidouleur par exemple pour les grands
brûlés on peut les imaginer projeter
dans un dans un univers glacé pour pour
leur permettre de supporter les soins ou
alors pour guérir des phobies moi j'ai
essayé un casque de réalité virtuelle
pour le vertige c'est étonnant comme
c'est réalistes ou alors peur de la
foule donc tout ce qui est rééducation
postée etc là ça peut avoir un intérêt
après moi c'est tout l'objet de mon
livre c'est que sinon je n'aurais pas
fait un polar d'ailleurs c'est que je
pense que c'est la porte ouverte à de
graves dérives alors
avant d'aller dans les dérives
psychologiques que moi j'ai surtout
traité dans le livre dans
il y a une un problème qui a été qui a
été pointé par notre agence nationale de
sécurité par l'ancêtre en juin 2021 il y
a eu un rapport sur la réalité virtuelle
si on passe notre temps avec les casques
de réalité virtuelle sur la tête et là
encore c'était une heure par jour donc
c'était pas non plus toute la journée et
bien on a un risque de
cybersinettose qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
les pathologies du à la réalité
virtuelle alors donc on a des nausées
des vertiges de la confusion des
problèmes de motricité des problèmes de
sommeil aussi parce qu'on peut imaginer
pas dommage je vais me lancer dans le
métabère mais alors je vais vous
redonner la parole évidemment mais il y
a un aspect très important je voudrais
qu'on ne parle tout de suite puis
ensuite on va vraiment développer
l'aspect environnemental c'est la
question de la de la loi quoi de la
réglementation ou de cet espace c'est un
peu un espace de non-droit aujourd'hui
écoutons ce que Thierry Breton enfin
plutôt on va le dire ce que Thierry
Botton disait il y a une semaine le
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
c'était sur sur un blog ce nouvel
environnement virtuel doit intégrer dès
le départ les valeurs européennes les
gens devraient sentir aussi en sécurité
dans les mondes virtuel que dans le
monde réel nous n'assisterons pas un
nouveau Far West ou à de nouveaux
monopole privé nous avons l'intention de
façonner dès le départ le développement
de metaves vraiment sûr et prospère à ce
moment-là vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est trop vague pour l'instant
mais il y a quand même plusieurs enjeux
il y a les enjeux effectivement de de
justice qu'est-ce qui se passe sur le
métaverse est-ce que c'est condamnable
ou pas et puis il y a les enjeux de bras
de fer économiques est-ce que l'Europe
laisse la main aux géants américains ou
éventuellement asiatique si vous
permettez je vais vous faire le topo de
l'ensemble des enjeux qui sont posés
parce que il y en a quatre ou cinq mais
qui sont absolument majeurs majeurs et
le metavin c'est absolument pas du tout
ce petit truc ludique et sympathique ou
pas ou de divertissement pour faire du
shopping c'est beaucoup plus
potentiellement grave que le premier
enjeu c'est un enjeu géopolitique on a
vu à l'aune de la guerre en Ukraine ou
au Sahel ce qu'on appelle la guerre
d'informationnelle via les réseaux
sociaux demain ce qui va se passer sur
le métaver potentiellement c'est sur la
partie des simulations du cyber
terrorisme des simulations d'attentats
des guerres cognitives et non plus
simplement informationnel ou chacun
d'entre nous nos cerveaux vont devenir
potentiellement des armes passives du
narratif de l'adversaire de l'ennemi etc
donc pour bien comprendre on pourrait se
faire influencer par l'ennemi via ces
univers dans lequel on serait plongé ce
sont des espaces en fait et ce sont des
espaces toutes vos capacités de
discernement sont très en moins de ris
parce que c'est immersif et parce que a
priori vous créez du lien même s'il est
virtuel et doit être plus sensible
malléable aux manipulations ou à la
propagande ça c'est le premier gros
enjeu c'est la question de la future
génération des guerres informations
nationales ce qu'on appelle les guerres
cognitives et donc de cyber terrorisme
par ailleurs donc les simulations
d'attentat le deuxième enjeu c'est le
l'enjeu de la souveraineté technologique
européenne et française c'est un peu ce
qui évoqué le tiré breton dans son dans
son communiqué mais il ne pousse pas le
sujet jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que lui
il part du principe qu'il faut
absolument sécuriser une partie des
infrastructures parce que le métaver
c'est aussi des infrastructures le Cloud
la data les semi-conducteurs etc donc
tout ce qui va pousser et tout ce qui va
supporter cette infrastructure là on est
un tout petit peu nu en Europe sur ces
questions là on n'est pas du tout au
niveau donc la question de construire
son métaver il y a la question de
l'Infra et puis ensuite si on n'a pas
demain les moyens financiers techniques
technologique de le faire on va être en
fait complètement tributeur des
Américains potentiellement qui eux vont
construire un métaverte selon leur
vision du monde selon leur idéologie
très très rapidement je vous laisse
après Mathieu ou intervenir oui moi je
voulais comprendre franchement j'y
connais rien est-ce qu'on ne pourra pas
se passer du métal vert en gros est-ce
que ça va être comme internet on peut
toujours se passer d'internet mais c'est
de plus en plus compliqué de vivre
aujourd'hui dans un monde quand on n'est
pas connecté est-ce que demain ça sera
la même chose ou est-ce que c'est une
espèce d'espace ludique pour des gens
qui aiment bien vivre virtuellement tout
va dépendre du fait enfin tout va
dépendre de savoir si la mayonnaise va
prendre ou pas en terme d'usage donc
demain on va voir des usages qui sont
très fluides et on va avoir une
désirabilité une accoutumance comme ce
qu'on a vu en fait jusque là avec les
réseaux sociaux ou tout un tas de sujets
à ce moment-là on va avoir d'énormes
potentiellement si on ne borde pas si on
prend pas le sujet d'avance si le truc
prend pas et ça reste simplement du
storytelling californien avec une
expérience un tout petit peu mauvaise ou
pas à la hauteur bon bah on reporte de
temps le sujet mais ce que disait Elena
était très intéressant parce que dans le
méta vert version Zuckerberg en fait ce
sont des vieux imaginaires c'est des
imaginaires science-fiction des années
60-70 visuellement pour l'instant c'est
assez rustique on va dire que ça donne
pas très envie d'y aller c'est quoi le
troisième enjeu en deux mots juridique
voulez-vous juridique on va y venir le
l'enjeu juridique de l'avatar le statut
de l'avatar alors ça je trouve ça très
intéressant et Nacer vous avez une
histoire enfin une info assez
récente d'accusation de de viol
d'agression sexuelle sur le métabolisme
deux agressions sexuelles dans le
métaverse de deux jeunes
pour moi le métabère c'est les Sims vous
voyez ça
et donc c'est un avatar qui a attaqué
violé un autre avatar
testeuses c'est quelqu'un qui teste donc
le métabex pour l'améliorer elle a mis
son casque elle donc sous forme d'avatar
elle s'est projetée dans le jeu et très
rapidement d'autres avatars sont arrivés
sur elle ont commencé à la tripoter
comme elle dit elle s'est sentie
extrêmement mal et surtout qu'elle
disait qu'il y avait des observateurs
qui l'observaient qui n'ont pas bougé
donc elle a enlevé le casque elle était
elle était vraiment très très choquée
mais on peut le comprendre parce que
quand on essaye la réalité virtuelle je
sais pas si tous vous avez mis déjà un
casque de réalité
sur la tête c'est tellement réaliste on
peut y croire oui effectivement
suite à ça parce que ça fait scandale
évidemment suite à ça meta a décidé
d'avoir un bouton STOP un bouton de
sécurité donc alors imaginez quand même
imaginez c'est à dire que je suis
via mon avatar sur dans le métaverse et
je me sens j'ai peur je me balade dans
une nuit dans une rue sombre le soir et
j'ai peur j'appuie sur mon bouton de
sécurité à ce moment-là se crée une
bulle de sécurité d'un mètre 20 autour
de moi et personne peut m'approcher
quand on est le cerveau finit par y
croire
je pose des questions
que la sensation d'insécurité peut-être
tout à fait la même que dans une rue
réelle mais ce qui est terrible c'est
que ce qui est terrible en tout cas si
en question là c'est que l'avatar n'est
pas une personne
n'est pas considéré je vous redonne la
parole puisque c'était votre troisième
point pour l'instant c'est quoi c'est un
espace de non-droit c'est à dire que
quelqu'un qui viole
via son avatar sur le méta vert Matthieu
voilà je mettais vous à la place de
celle qui l'a subi et qui le vit mal ça
ne peut pas que faire
est-ce que celui qui viole le risque
quelque chose dans ce monde virtuel
alors
trois choses un on a aujourd'hui le DSA
digital services qui est potentiellement
pourrait on ne sait pas encore on verra
comment la Commission européenne va
évoluer en termes de doctrine sur le
site sur le sujet mais pourraient
peut-être cadrer ou encadrer la question
de des méta vert premier point donc si
c'est le cas bon on a un début de 1 je
deviens un début de réponse pas
lancèrent la réponse 2 tout dépend de ce
dont on parle si c'est des cas après qui
deviennent ou qui convergent vers du
cyber-harcèlement classique là c'est le
cadre juridique actuel légal pénal qui
s'applique il n'y a aucun problème
aucune ambiguïté sur le sujet si en
revanche c'est l'avatar qui est en fait
la victime de ce qui se passe on a en
effet une question juridique
existentielle fondamentale l'avatar est
une extension de votre personne ou et
doit-il être un sujet de droit ou pas
se penchent sur la question
un peu obligés de le faire bref on va
tout ce que j'entends depuis depuis le
début de ce débat ça me donne déjà envie
tout simplement de répondre à la
question bah on en a vraiment besoin non
et il faut surtout faut pas y aller et
espérons que ça prendra pas mais il y a
alors un autre aspect qui est très
important c'est l'aspect environnemental
et je vous propose alexandre Poussin de
nous rejoindre pour expliquer en
quelques en quelques chiffres et en
quelques mots en quoi ce coup
environnemental du métaver pose de plus
en plus question et bien il faut déjà se
remettre dans le contexte du coup
environnemental du numérique en général
et on va citer un rapport du Sénat qui
dit que en France en 2019 et bien le
numérique représente 2% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre mais que cette
empreinte écologique du numérique va
tripler 20 ans plus tard alors c'est un
rapport qui date de 2020 un moment ou
peut-être on se posait pas encore la
question du coût écologique du métaver
mais ces derniers temps certains se la
pose et non notamment certains du monde
du jeu vidéo qui tire la sonnette
d'alarme avec une tribune qui a été
publiée par une centaine de développeurs
de jeux vidéo qui dénonce le gouffre
énergétique que représenterait le
développement du metaves je cite cette
tribune chaque seconde au moins 30
images doivent s'enchaîner afin que
l'expérience reste pas la plus fluide
possible pour le public on atteint même
les 90 images par seconde dans le cas de
la réalité virtuelle elle s'est
enchaînement rapide gourmand donné en
puissance de calcul entraîne une très
forte consommation d'énergie bien plus
que la vidéo classique on peut citer
également un rapport de l'entreprise
américaine d'informatique à Cisco qui
affirme que le streaming vidéo en
réalité virtuelle va multiplier par 30
les besoins de bande passante sur les
réseaux par rapport aux techniques
actuelles et globalement et bien les
sources de surconsommation du metaves
sont les datacenters les centres de
stockage de données qui consomment
beaucoup d'énergie mais surtout la
fabrication des équipements numériques
donc les casques de réalité virtuelle et
puis les écrans qui nécessitent
l'extraction de métaux rares des
équipements qui sont fabriqués en Chine
alors ça se c'est vraiment la
démonstration d'un métabère polluant
mais il y a un argument qui consiste à
dire ça nous évite de nous déplacer oui
c'est le principal argument des
défenseurs du metaves notamment de
facebook cet univers virtuel aurait des
bienfaits technologique car il économise
des déplacements on pourrait aller faire
ses courses sans se déplacer faire des
voyages virtuels sans prendre l'avion ou
encore faire des réunions virtuelles
professionnelles c'est un petit peu ce
qu'on a vu pendant l'année avec avec les
visions conférences et des chercheurs
qui montraient que c'est réunions
professionnelles ces rencontres
professionnelles et bien ça permettait
d'économiser et bien en tout cas elles
étaient des dizaines et des dizaines de
fois moins polluantes que des réunions
en présentiel mais en face et bien les
écologistes sont un peu sceptiques sur
ces arguments regardez ce que dit par
exemple le président de l'Alliance Green
IT qui a travaillé sur ce sujet je le
chite je le cite je ne pense pas que
visiter l'Australie dans le métabère
permettra de réduire l'empreinte carbone
la sensation des doigts de pied en
éventail dans le sable et incomparable
c'est seulement un moyen d'en faire une
publicité plus efficace donc voilà pas
sûr qu'on diminue nos déplacement avec
le métal ça donne envie de vacances
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est d'abord
de nous vendre de nouveaux objets
connectés
sauf qu'il faut les produire ces objets
alors il faut les produire il y a
plusieurs choses déjà il y a un truc qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on parle au
futur depuis tout à l'heure où ça va
arriver c'est pas dit c'est pas dit que
nos fantasmes se réalisent et on
commence à être dans un monde où ça
serait une bonne idée qu'on intègre
vraiment ça dans nos discours
ça fait des dizaines d'années que
n'importe quel modèle qui décrit
physiquement l'économie nous dit qu'il y
a des ressources finies que quand il y a
des ressources finies à un moment il y
en a plus alors ça a l'air très
compliqué c'est vraiment un tas de sable
si je prends du sable il y a un moment
il y a plus de sable c'est aussi bête
que ça c'est ça le théorème des
accroissements finis bon donc
plus on avance moins on a de ressources
disponibles ces ressources on les a
utilisées pour faire des choses dont la
DG la 3G la 4G là on propose de déployer
des nouvelles des nouveaux réseaux des
nouvelles infrastructures etc parce que
pour bien comprendre déployer le métaver
c'est forcément avec de nouvelles
infrastructures avec de nouveaux on l'a
dit de nouveaux matériaux des casques
etc il faut la 5G pour que ça marche
pour que ça marche bien c'est ça il faut
enfin
c'est c'est tout sauf neutre quoi c'est
ça en fait faut plus de bandes passantes
et la bande passante c'est de la taille
de tuyaux vous faites passer des données
dans de la fibre optique et dans des
réseaux de d'accès c'est de la taille de
tuyaux donc si vous avez besoin de plus
de données qu'avant vous avez besoin de
plus gros tuyau et du coup d'interface
parce que personne ici n'est capable de
capter le wifi avec ses yeux je crois
donc on a besoin d'interface aujourd'hui
c'est ça on a un écran qui capte le wifi
et qui nous rend ça intelligible là il
faudra un casque de réalité virtuelle
pour que ce soit immersif tout ça c'est
du matériel
le compte qui raconte que le numérique
est immatériel et résolument faux c'est
des millions de c'est l'infrastructure
la plus grande et la plus matérielle
qu'on ait fait sur Terre avec notamment
et là on en revient à la démonstration
vous nous faites sur le tas de sable il
y a des métaux qui s'appellent qu'on les
métaux rares par définition ils sont
rares et donc on sait à quelle échéance
ils vont s'épuiser à notre rythme de
fabrication de d'outils et d'objets
numériques c'est très compliqué parce
qu'il y a des contraintes géologiques
etc en fait ce qu'il faut garder en tête
c'est que concrètement plus on creuse
moi il y en a c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a
mais ça devient plus difficile de les
sortir c'est des roches qui sont moins
pures qu'avant donc ça va devenir de
plus en plus difficile et dans ce
contexte on ça devient de plus en plus
difficile nous on est en train de dire
on va faire des dizaines de milliards
d'objets connectés dans le monde
tranquillement pas besoin de
planification stratégique il y a une
question faut comprendre que c'est les
mêmes matériaux qui sont utilisés pour
d'autres trucs pour la transition
énergétique pour des applications en
médecine et donc
du coup la question qui se pose sur le
metaves puisqu'on sait même pas
exactement ce que c'est c'est à quoi ça
sert escalier d'endroit où ça peut
vraiment être utile et c'est assez
récurrent pour la 5G le débat a pas
réussi à se cristalliser autrement que
pour ou contre personne n'a proposé n'a
vraiment réussi à discuter de quels
usages pourquoi faire quand on est dans
un monde avec des ressources contraintes
vous avez un budget contraint par mois
vous réfléchissez à ce que vous dépensez
c'est aussi bête que ça et aujourd'hui
on n'est pas encore relatent on pense
encore que les ressources sont infinies
et que pour le numérique parce que c'est
cool et parce que les financements les
raffinis on peut y aller non c'est même
dangereux en fait de construire une
infrastructure numérique qu'on n'est pas
sûr de pouvoir faire fonctionner dans
des conditions qui vont devenir plus
contraintes dans les 10 à 30 prochaines
années c'est dangereux j'ai une petite
hypothèse pour essayer de craquer cette
question qui étonne un peu tout le monde
qui est ce système schizophrène ou
schizophrénie entre l'innovation pour
l'innovation
[Musique]
sans fin dans une espèce de course sans
fin et puis un monde finit en fait en
termes de ressources et en réalité on ne
peut le comprendre ce qui se passe avec
facebook meta Zuckerberg musk etc que si
on comprend ce que sont que ces géants
technologiques et qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
ils sont des entités politiques
géopolitiques des bras armés
technologiques de l'État américain qui
dans une course aujourd'hui dans une
même une guerre en fait technologique
avec la Chine et pas que et donc de ce
point de vue là arrêtez cette innovation
arrêtez les géants technologiques dans
cette course là est un non-sens d'un
point de vue politique d'un point de vue
de Power politique américain et pourquoi
en particulier le métabère peut être
intéressant parce que c'est une source
de données infinie parce que derrière on
peut récupérer quoi vos données
biométriques votre iris faire des bases
de données et donc continuer le système
de surveillance généralisée de masse
tout simplement c'est flippant c'est de
la réelle politique
vraiment en citoyen de de base c'est
c'est parfaitement effrayant Mathieu
est-ce qu'on peut contrôler je vois bien
le la fonctionnalité de de e-commerce au
fond c'est plus amusant qu'un écran
d'ordinateur oui parce qu'on se balade
dans le magasin et on peut toucher je
sais pas comment mais on peut on peut
voir mieux les objets avec les gants
juste pour que je comprenne c'est à dire
que je vais avoir je vais ressentir sur
mes gants comme si je touchais du
velours ou comme si je touchais du satin
ou de la soie
et en fait c'est ça qui va permettre la
coutumance on va vous endormir avec ce
premier usage et après il y a l'autre
fonction vous disiez en gros gigantesque
réseau social mais alors là pour le coup
avec des avatars où on se verra plutôt
que de s'appeler Scooby-Doo 75 on verra
ce que oui 12 75 ça y est on connaît
votre avatar
et là est-ce qu'on va contrôler ce que
disent qu'on veut Scooby-Doo 75 parce
que comment on commence à se passer
parce qu'on sait que sur les réseaux
sociaux actuels c'est déjà très
compliqué est-ce qu'on peut contrôler ce
qui se dit une excellente question c'est
la question de la modération
quels sont qu'elles vont être les
nouveaux outils de modération et
maintenant on évoquait un le bouton etc
mais il va y avoir cette question là
c'est pour ça que j'évoquais le DSA tout
à l'heure et puis surtout ça veut dire
que c'est digital services actes grand
texte réglementaire de la Commission
européenne pour réglementer réguler
taper sur les doigts des big tech et en
particulier des réseaux sociaux
quand ils en freignent la loi
et l'autre question que que qu'en fait
vous posez en filigrane c'est la
question de la cybersécurité et donc des
attaques c'est à dire qu'au
potentiellement tout ce qui peut chuter
en termes de données quoi je reviens à
l'aspect environnemental et Léa sender
on a parlé des objets il y a aussi les
les centres de données les Data Center
là aussi
j'avais j'avais une question c'est que
quand même à l'heure où on parle on
essaye de diviser par deux nos émissions
de CO2 n'est-ce pas de gaz à effet de
serre plus généralement et là avec une
puissance nécessaire qui va être
multipliée par 1000 en tout cas c'est ce
que j'ai lu pour pouvoir avoir un
métaver plus des Data Center donc c'est
ces énormes
entrepôts de base de données que l'on
doit refroidir
avec de l'énergie donc on va émettre
beaucoup beaucoup de gaz à effet de
serre si l'énergie est une énergie
fossile utilisée on parlait de
schizophrénie j'aime pas trop utiliser
ce mot mais oui on est on en est pas là
on devrait plutôt s'occuper déjà de
réduire nos gaz à effet de serre plutôt
que de multiplier encore notre nos
besoins en énergie est-ce que cette
question elle est posée
je vous donne la parole est-ce qu'elle
est posée par qui est posée par le
chiffre
il y a beaucoup d'acteurs qui la pose et
particulièrement en France et en Europe
est-ce qu'elle est posée par la
commission ou par l'Europe de manière
générale je marche pas si on regarde par
exemple la lettre d'intention de cela
Finder layonne il y a trois occurrences
qui concernent l'environnement le climat
etc il y en a deux à trois fois plus je
crois avec le mot numérique et coller
les deux on a un peu du mal on parle du
coup on parle des impacts j'ai pas parlé
de ce que ça pouvait éviter du potentiel
positif d'un point de vue bilan carbone
aujourd'hui le numérique n'a jamais
permis d'éviter des émissions au
globales c'est à dire que le l'effet de
substitution c'est-à-dire je vais faire
des visioconférences donc on ne va plus
se déplacer de compensent pas
la pollution créée par numérique il y a
des effets rebonds permanents donc on
améliore l'efficacité énergétique mais
du coup ça coûte moins cher donc on
n'utilise plus et du coup ça monte donc
aujourd'hui le numérique c'est ce qu'on
a entendu tout à l'heure c'est aux
alentours de 4% des émissions du monde
donc c'était 2% en 2019 c'est 40%
aujourd'hui 2% en France c'est 4% dans
le monde au niveau mondial 6% par an
c'est beaucoup
les émissions mondiales aujourd'hui on
doit les réduire de 5% par an ça
augmente tranquillement de 2 à 3% par an
le numérique c'est deux fois plus vite
et vous l'avez vu les émissions
continuent d'augmenter alors il y a
plein d'effets mais le numérique seul
n'a jamais permis de susciter quoi que
ce soit et du coup les usages s'empilent
je finis juste là-dessus les usages sont
piles et quand on dit que on utilisera
le métaverse est plus internet classique
ouais on avait dit pareil avec les
bouquins on avait dit pareil avec les
mobiles par rapport aux ordinateurs non
on empile les usages plaisants sur les
autres Elena et puis il y a notre effet
c'est que sur le métaver on paye en
crypto monnaie et la crypto monnaie elle
nécessite un minage c'est à dire elle
nécessite des des vérifications par
calcul qui nécessitent une une puissance
encore une fois de calcul phénoménal
donc si en plus toutes les transactions
se font enfin dites moi si je me trompe
mais mais ce sont pas crypto monnaie on
a grave encore le problème à mon avis
alors je voudrais qu'on un chapitre ce
qu'on parle aussi business où nous
l'avez dit c'est un endroit où on peut
acheter en virtuel ou pas cette
technologie elle alors là on parle plus
des NFC on va expliquer ce que c'est
en train de bouleverser le monde de
l'art et des collectionneurs
explications de Samia de chir avec
Moutou
une collectionneuse dans l'âme c'est sa
manière de soutenir les artistes il y a
deux ans elle a élargi son terrain de
jeu à un nouvel univers les NFC un jour
je suis tombé sur cet artiste qui
s'appelle Norman Hermann et cette oeuvre
là en fait qui est ça tombe bien c'est
la reine d'Angleterre en fait
donc je sais pas j'ai eu un coup de cœur
en fait sur cette oeuvre là et en fait à
partir du moment où j'ai eu cette œuvre
une espèce de truc qui s'est enclenché
qui sait pas arrêter depuis elle en
possède désormais plus de 600 un NFC non
Fogi boltoken est un certificat de
propriété d'un fichier numérique on les
achète en crypto monnaie du type Bitcoin
ou éther sur des plateformes en ligne
les œuvres restent reproductibles à
l'infini mais vous en êtes l'unique
propriétaire certains les affichent sur
des écrans Albertine meunier préfère les
stocker sur son ordinateur ou sur son
téléphone dans la collection d’œuvres
digitales en fait on n'a pas
on n'a pas cette nécessité de
l'accrocher au mur parce qu'en fait ce
qui est important dans le NFC c'est
c'est plus cette idée d'être
propriétaire d'une image que tout le
monde peut voir en fait plus une oeuvre
est vue bizarrement plus elle a de la
valeur alors qu'avant c'était plutôt
l'inverse plus une oeuvre est cachée et
plus elle les rares c'est un marché en
pleine expansion au cœur de Paris un
lieu de 400 mètres carrés entièrement
dédié au NFC va ouvrir ses portes
mi-octobre à sa tête la co-fondatrice
d'une importante maison de vente aux
enchères séduite par cet univers qui
rassemble tout type d'acheteurs il va y
avoir à la fois quelques ce qu'on
appelle des Wales c'était très gros
collectionneurs qui ont un mouvement
investir des millions mais la fois
beaucoup beaucoup de tout petits
collectionneurs parce qu'il y a des
plateformes sur lesquelles on peut
trouver des oeuvres à quelques tes os
qui sont en fait quelques euros ce qui
permet finalement une accessibilité au
marché de l'art qu'on connaît absolument
pas dans le marché d'art traditionnel
les NFC c'est une petite révolution
attendue depuis longtemps par les
artistes numériques pour pouvoir vivre
de leur art Gauthier Vernier et membre
du collectif obvious un trio qui crée
des oeuvres à l'aide de l'intelligence
artificielle comme cette collection de
mille NFT des visuels de rêve et de
cauchemars générés par des algorithmes
on a créé les mille NFT ils ont tous été
vendus à 0,1 et terre donc ce qui
correspond environ à
150 euros aujourd'hui
ils ont été tous vendus en moins de deux
minutes et après en fait c'est le second
marché qui se développe et donc
aujourd'hui par exemple il est
disponible pour 258 euros à chaque fois
qu'une de ces œuvres est revendu il
touche
une des spécificités des NFC dont on
peut retracer tous les achats inscrits
dans la blockchain une sorte de serveur
mondial décentralisé où sont stockés des
transactions un des intérêts des NFT
c'est le fait que en fait ça a permis de
mettre en place les droits de suite donc
les droits de fuite c'est le fait qu'un
artiste touche une rémunération à chaque
fois que son
œuvre est revendu donc entre deux
collectionneurs c'est quelque chose
qu'on a essayé d'implémenter en France
avec l'art classique et qui est en fait
très dur à suivre et en fait avec la NFT
c'est super facile l'autre intérêt des
NFC c'est aussi une manière différente
de créer grâce aux communautés en ligne
les artistes peuvent échanger avec les
acheteurs avant et après la vente pour
faire évoluer leurs œuvres
et il y a de plus en plus de marques qui
qui investissent alors soit dans les MST
ces oeuvres d'art numérique des
collections de basket pour les avatars
des magasins virtuels en a parlé pour
passer les commandes regardez les
marques qui sont déjà présentes dans ces
usages dont je parle vous allez les voir
s'afficher Nike L'Oréal Disney Gucci
Puma Apple McDonald Microsoft Carrefour
dans le patron alexandre Bompard a même
fait passer des entretiens d'embauche
dans le métabère c'était il y a quelques
semaines regardez à quoi ça ressemble on
entend sa voix
bonjour à toutes et bonjour à tous je
suis
ravi de faire ses premiers pas dans le
dans le métaverse avec vous et ravi de
vous retrouver pour ce moment assez
exceptionnel
exceptionnelle il est pour plein de
raisons
d'abord parce qu'il est très nouveau
c'est le premier événement de
recrutement de Carrefour dans le
métaverse et vous l'avez compris avec ma
démarche très sûre le premier pour moi
aussi
à ce moment là ils font quoi les marques
parce que là c'est quand même assez
ridicule bien d'accord je vois mort de
rire
[Musique]
ça ressemble à des jeux vidéo d'il y a
25 ans
il y en a des plus élaborés mais si ils
sont plus élaborés consomment plus de de
bande passante aussi j'imagine bref
qu'est-ce qu'ils font qu'est-ce qu'elle
recherche
tout simplement en fait ce sont des
relais de croissance alors pendant très
longtemps avec ce qu'on a appelé la
transformation digitale des
organisations on a eu ce qu'on appelle
l'omnicanal donc c'est à dire comment
est-ce qu'on crée des expériences
d'achat absolument fluides entre les
boutiques le virtuel e-commerce sans
couture de façon à ce que en fait on
maximise votre panier d'achat quoi donc
le chiffre d'affaires que vous générez
pour chaque marque c'est exactement la
même logique mais avec une possibilité
d'augmenter encore plus ce chiffre
d'affaires par justement ce côté hyper
immersif par le fait que vous êtes
complètement pris dans cet univers là et
que votre expérience d'achat serait
normalement en théorie encore plus sans
couture et encore plus fluide que ce
qu'on avait jusque là
Maxime et foues je l’évoquais à la le
métal imaginons moi j'espère que non
mais imaginons qu'il se développe que
nos que finalement ça devient nos usages
ces images que l'on voit là qui étaient
rustiques pour Carrefour elles vont
devenir de plus en plus on sera est-ce
qu'elles vont se rapprocher de ce qu'on
voit par exemple dans les meilleures
jeux vidéo aujourd'hui avec donc là
encore plus de pollution vous voyez ce
que je veux dire plus
il va être énergivore c'est ça c'est le
but parce que si on regardait un peu les
gens qui testent qui s'amusent au bout
de quelques heures dans un univers aussi
mal fait vous savez assez vite la nausée
donc si le truc doit marcher il faut
absolument que ça soit meilleur d'accord
c'est normal qui a envie de parler à des
gens avec des têtes triangulaires
donc forcément et oui c'est assez
mécanique pour avoir plus de résolution
bah en fait vous avez besoin de plus de
bande passante et du coup ça ça va
réclamer des infrastructures plus
grosses etc on revient au data center au
centre de exactement et il y a un effet
en plus qui est intéressant à voir en
tête encore une fois sur les
substitution on n'est pas en train de
dématérialiser l'économie c'est juste un
relais de croissance supplémentaire
les humains ont besoin de choses et
c'est rigolo parce que on dit que les
œuvres là du coup les NFT typiquement
c'est sur les œuvres virtuelles etc donc
c'est intouchable c'est comme ça on l'a
juste dans son disque dur super en
attendant on est en train de créer des
galeries pour faire quoi les afficher il
y a des effets de seuil on est quand
même des primates et les primates ils
aiment bien voir des choses et les
toucher voilà c'est qu'à faire
l'expérience mettez vous savez les
petits pics avec les petits les petits
moulins là vous placez ça dans une rue
les gens vont taper dedans pas parce
qu'on est des primates et du coup il y a
des effets de seuil qui font que notre
économie est réelle
et donc quand on rajoute du virtuel ça
accélère les flux de marchandises etc
donc on optimise nos flux physiques mais
ça ne les a jamais ralentis alors ça ça
pourrait d'une certaine façon je
reprends l'argument nous rassurer sur le
la capacité des humains peut-être se
débarrasser du Métavers sauf qu'il y a
cet aspect psychologique et on va
terminer à l'innote 5 6 minutes
là-dessus et c'est un peu le point de
départ de votre roman replay c'est
l'histoire d'un inventeur mégalo toxique
qui crée un jeu vidéo qui permet aux
utilisateurs de revivre leur passé et de
le changer sauf qu'après il y a le
retour à la réalité bien sûr et alors je
suis pas partie de rien c'est à dire que
j'ai vu cette vidéo qui pourrait être un
prémisse du métaver ou une maman
sud-coréenne qui avait perdu sa petite
fille d'une maladie incurable dans la
réalité je raconte une histoire vraie on
avait recréé dans le métaverse sa petite
fille donc c'est un avatar en tout point
correspondant à sa petite fille qui
parle comme elle qui bouge comme Alex
etc et donc là la maman désespérée porte
le casque et là on est dans un dans un
jardin merveilleux et la petite fille
sort du jardin se jette dans ses bras
elle a sans contraire bon alors c'est
cette vidéo que j'ai vu est déchirante
ça a été fait pour pour un documentaire
cette vidéo est déchirante mais ça
présage de ce qui risque de nous comment
peut-elle revenir dans dans le monde
réel où sa petite fille est morte quand
est-ce qu'on enlève le casque et alors
cette question de l'immortalité
numérique que adore nos géants de la
high-tech elle va se poser puisqu'on a
déjà des des startups qui travaillent à
nous rendre immortel dans le métabère
donc le jour de votre décès votre avatar
en tout point semblable à vous
avec vos idées le temps de votre voix
etc va pouvoir continuer à dialoguer
avec vous ça aussi c'est très important
parce que c'est un des enjeux du métaver
on est dans l'enjeu économique mais
aussi on est dans l'enjeu philosophie de
ne jamais mourir et alors évidemment il
y a beaucoup de psychologues qui
s'interrogent ils se disent mais est-ce
qu'on va pas déjà incréer des gens une
solitude c'est à dire qu'on va être
chacun dans nos appartements avec nos
casques dans des à se projeter dans dans
un univers alternatif ça pose question
et puis ah mais complètement parce qu'on
a eu de 56 ans qui qui court de moins en
moins vite sur les terrains de sport je
vais me créer un Thomas Hugue qui mesure
1m90 qui a un corps d'Apollon et qui
renforce le tournoi de tennis du métal
on peut vivre avec la mort c'est le
deuil de point zéro c'est fantastique
alors pour finir donc dans le livre je
soulève évidemment je vais jusqu'au bout
de la démonstration
j'aimerais juste sous vu ce que j'ai lu
il y a quelques jours que meta avait
quand même un groupe pour réfléchir à
l'éthique de ces pratiques donc ce qui
m'avait
rassurétion éthiques sur le métaverse il
vient d'être dissous
donc je voilà là là je commence à
m'inquiéter j'ai confiance dans les
autorités européennes qui sont
généralement un petit peu plus
d'innovation ah non j'ai pas dit ça non
mais volontaires dans la réflexion la
réflexion et règlements en revanche pour
nos amis américains j'en suis beaucoup
moins sûr et je pense qu'il va falloir
qu'on réfléchisse aux usages avant de se
lancer
ce que ce que vous nous disiez un
dernier témoignage qui on reste sur cet
aspect psychologique qui est passionnant
c'est celui de d'un autre romancier il
s'appelle Nathan Deveyre dans son roman
c'est les liens artificiels sélectionnés
dans dans la première liste du concours
pour cette année si l'histoire d'un prof
de piano qui est malheureux dans sa vie
réelle et donc il découvre le meta vert
où il peut être beau riche et laisser
libre cours à ses fantasmes on écoute
Nathan de verre
la promesse de ce métavère donc cet
anti-monde qu'il découvre un monde
virtuel où il vit à travers un avatar
c'est une promesse qui est
authentiquement merveilleuse qui propose
aux gens d'avoir une double vie qui
propose aux gens si vous voulez de se
dédoubler moi ce qui me fascine en tant
le regard de romancier c'est l'identité
manquée que nous avons tous en nous on a
tous des occasions ratées on a tous
quelqu'un d'autre qu'on aurait aimé être
ce que j'appelle dans mon roman un anti
moi et la révolution numérique et le
metavèrent en particulier donnera
l'occasion et donne l'occasion aux gens
de déployer cette deuxième possibilité
à ce moment-là quand j'entends ça je me
dis ça va marcher malheureusement il y a
des chances que ça marche pour aussi des
questions évoquer de politiques de
puissance alors la fin de l'interview de
Nathan dever qui est très intéressant
c'est que d'après lui le métaver
assassinerait le réel et c'est là où je
ne suis pas du tout d'accord le métaver
ne va pas assassiner le réel c'est pire
encore il le commodent c'est à dire il
lui donne un prix de marché il le
fragmente il devient un produit on est
en train en fait de donner une
transaction de créer des transactions
sur des absolue et ça c'est extrêmement
dangereux d'un point de vue même du
projet de vie collective en fait Maxime
et foues est-ce qu'on peut encore
arrêter la machine
ou est-ce que c'est déjà trop tard ben
moi j'ai envie de poser la question
l'autre sens du est-ce que ça va marcher
ou pas c'est ce qu'on veut que ça marche
les services numériques ça se déploie
parce que collectivement pouvoir publier
comme on finance des choses on installe
des tuyaux on installe des antennes il
faut le faire marcher ce truc bien sûr
ça c'est massif donc la question se pose
est-ce qu'on veut que ça marche et il y
a les questions éthiques les questions
légales les risques géopolitiques il y a
les risques physiques et il y a la
question de est-ce qu'on veut le
prioriser par rapport aux autres choses
qu'on doit gérer aujourd'hui
et donc évidemment je prends ma
casquette matériaux énergique climat
mais comme c'est des budgets des budgets
énergétiques des budgets matières des
budgets carbone est-ce qu'on décide de
prioriser ça est-ce que vous décidez de
dépenser 500 euros dans un truc où vous
êtes pas sûr que c'est utile ou est-ce
que vous décidez de vous avez juste à un
endroit donc c'est vraiment la question
c'est comment on le déploie et est-ce
qu'on le priorise et qu'est-ce qu'on
priorise dans le métal vert tant qu'on
n'a pas posé cette question on est dans
le fantasme et c'est dangereux d'être
dans le fantasme dans un monde contraint
c'est dangereux merci beaucoup c'était
passionnant j'espère suffisamment
pédagogique pour tous ceux qui comme
Mathieu et moi ni connaissez absolument
rien ou quasiment rien merci à tous de
d'être venu sur ce plateau et à vous de
votre fidélité demain c'est Mathieu
justement qui qui tient la baraque
puisque je serai au Congrès des pompiers
de France pour soutenir notamment
l'association dont je suis le parrain
les orphelins qui s'occupent des qui
accompagnent les orphelins des des
pompiers voilà c'est à Nancy et j'y
serai demain et vendredi votre prochain
rendez-vous politique dans bonjour chez
vous oriente
Johanna Roland la mère de Nantes c'est à
8h demain matin sur Public Sénat belle
soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]